leute sie sind alle loser leona scheer
apa/red den aks biegsamen des offline
uwe und so weiter und so fort
ihr mit euren luschen karren ein paar
hundert ps geben erklären bmw um an das
ich nicht lache ich mache jetzt mal eine
ansage mehr als 10.000 ps damit bin ich
unterwegs wie was wieso weshalb warum
okay ihr sollt nicht dumm sterben hier
kommt die auflösung bei pixum science
fiction herzlich willkommen ja super
ledersitze steckdosen panoramafenster
mit sonnenblenden autonomes fahren
tabletts an jedem platz elektrische
türen zweifarblackierung rennerod
aufweise bedienung am platz kaiser café
warme speisen ja ich fahre siemens ab
trans das sind nämlich die hersteller
meines neuen gefährts ein icd 3v der
fährt nämlich ab dem 10
dezember mit 300 kilometern pro stunde
zwischen münchen und berlin in unter
vier stunden
ich war bei der jungfernfahrt dabei hier
erreichen wir gerade die
höchstgeschwindigkeit kurz vor erfurt
damit ist er locker schneller als das
flugzeug zwischen den beiden großstädten
mit fahrt zum flughafen
sicherheitskontrolle boarding dem
langwierigen einsteigen
sicherheitseinweisung und in münchen dem
extra langen und teuren weg zum
flughafen bei mir in berlin steige ich
direkt vor der haustüre in u oder s bahn
oder in einer regionalbahn und nach
einem umstieg dann direkt in der
münchner innenstadt wieder aus und
umgekehrt und das beste im zug kann
nicht schlafen oder arbeiten oder lesen
oder filme gucken oder oder oder und
verplempere nicht meine zeit mit checks
und 1000 wegen fliegen ist da echt die
solche und wer mit der bahncard fährt
ist mit 100 prozent ökostrom unterwegs
also viel umweltfreundlicher als mit dem
flugzeug und dabei sind die ice3 züge
technisch der absolute hammer der ec3
wird nämlich nicht von loks angetrieben
sondern die motoren sind unter den
waggons verteilt vier der acht wagen
sind angetrieben
dadurch bildet der zug eine feste
einheit und ist nicht wie ic züge die
durch ein log angetrieben werden nach
belieben zusammenstellen
durch diesen antrieb ergeben sich aber
einige vorteile der ec3 hat zum beispiel
eine
ziemlich beeindruckende beschleunigung
bei der abfahrt fühlt man sich wie in
einem auto so flott geht es los der
antrieb ist mit 4 500 kilowatt motoren
unter den angetriebenen waggons das sind
jeweils knapp 700 ps rund doppelt so
stark motorisiert wie die vorgänger
damit kann der ec3 sogar steigungen von
40 prozent überwinden deshalb würde auch
ausschließlich zwischen frankfurt und
köln eingesetzt weil es auf dieser
trasse genau diese steigerung gibt
nachteil die ersten ic3 waren ziemlich
seitenwind empfindlich damit sie nicht
aus den gleisen gedrückt wurden wurden
die strecken so gebaut dass sie vom
seitenwind geschützt sind wind
messgeräte ermitteln zusätzlich die
ständig die windgeschwindigkeiten und
setzten im zweifelsfall die
maximalgeschwindigkeiten auf den trassen
nach unten und in den end wagen der zuge
wurden 1,5 tonnen zusatzgewichte
eingebaut aber so oder so müssen ihn ce
strecken ganz bestimmte bedingungen
erfüllen um so graber umso besser die
spitzengeschwindigkeit von 300
kilometern pro stunde zwischen münchen
und berlin
die ist nur auf einer ziemlich geraden
strecke zu erreichen dementsprechend
gibt es auf der neubautrasse ohne ende
tunnel und brücken 29 talbrücken und 22
tunnel sind es genau
sogar der meinen also der fluss wurde
verlegt und renaturiert also tiere haben
jetzt hier einen deutlich verbesserten
lebensraum sieht man ja ganz gut und das
alles hat die trasse auch extrem teuer
gemacht zehn milliarden euro standen am
schluss auf der rechnung die hälfte war
geplant
ich bin jedenfalls super happy und werde
jetzt sicher öfter mal in münchen sein
innerdeutsche flüge gehören damit für
mich der vergangenheit an
kleine anmerkung noch zum schluss mein
zug in dem ich dann nicht mehr wahr ist
übrigens auf der rückfahrt nach münchen
liegen geblieben
technische störungen schließlich kam er
mit zwei stunden und zehn minuten
verspätung in münchen am hauptbahnhof an
um 125 hoffen wir mal dass der
planmäßige start planmäßiger
vonstattengeht verspätung gibt es ja bei
der bahn leider so regelmäßig dass man
fast seine uhr danach stellen kann
paradox hierauf blick so kümmere ich
mich öfter solche verkehrsthemen wenn er
kein video dazu in zukunft verpassen
wollt dann drückt mir hier ein abo aufs
auge und vergesst nicht den genau auf
die glocke
denn nur dann verpasst er auch kein
video hier geht es weiter mit der
verkehr der zukunft vorbild china dafür
drauf klicken
extrem spannend was entwickelt wird
ansonsten bis dann bleibt dran